et je vous le disais en début d'édition
il va y avoir du sport à présent dans le
7 8 on va parler de la diagonale des
Yvelines ou la diag 78 appelée là comme
vous voulez la quatrième édition de
cette compétition et programmée ce
samedi 1er avril elle proposera
différents formats pour les trailers
dans les Yvelines avec notamment un 100
km entre Breuil Bois Robert et Rochefort
en Yvelines différents invités sont avec
nous en plateau je le disais
Jean-Baptiste amonic également à Laurent
Pallot qui sont avec nous et on a été
rejoint par Alain pelos bonsoir bonsoir
et que vous êtes vous l'organisateur
justement de cette diag 78 4e édition
pour cet événement qui prend de
l'ampleur on peut le dire d'année en
année on monte en puissance pour pour
cet événement oui tout à fait puisque là
on est à près de 900 coureurs la
dernière on était à 450 donc 900
coureurs cette année on est très très
content ça a bien bien fonctionné je
pense que la mayonnaise a pris je pense
que le le parcours plaît au coureur et
le concept plaît au trailer aussi donc
on est très très content et puis je
pense que ça ça fait que ça va faire que
continuer donc vous l'avez dit beaucoup
de participantes c'est à dire que là on
va battre les précédents records là on
va être sur l'édition qui a attiré le
plus de participants tout à fait ouais
tout à fait alors c'est vrai que il y a
des petits changements qui a peut-être
permis tout ça puisque il y a le 20 km
et 12 km qui est en boucle autour de
Rochefort mais on a les profs phares le
100 km et le 50 km qui ont pris beaucoup
on est pas loin de 150 coureurs sur le
sein le sang km ce qui est quand même
une performance parce que tout le monde
ne court pas 100 km et on est pas loin
de 300 350 sur le 50 km donc c'est on
est très très content donc différents
parcours qu'on va détailler dans un
instant on a suivi déjà plusieurs
trailers sur TV 78 certains ont décidé
par exemple de quitter les co-trails de
Paris on le suivait la semaine dernière
au départ de l'île de loisirs de 50 ans
en Yvelines jusqu'à la tour Eiffel pour
participer à votre événement comment
vous l'expliquer
alors comment je l'explique je pense que
le fait qu'on traverse un département le
principe de traverser un département je
pense que c'est un concept qui plaisait
et qui plaît le fait que vraiment les
Yvelines c'est un département rural
très nature on passe de différentes de
pleines de forêt de forêts d'hiver et il
y a un final qui est assez
fantastique je pense que tous ces
ingrédients font que
je pense qu'on peut attirer du monde qui
est forcément différent de du concept de
l'équateur qui reste quand même une
course majeure mais peut-être plusieurs
bennes voilà mais je fais réagir aussi
les autres invités Jean-Baptiste
amonique qu'est-ce qu'il fait à votre
avis le succès de de cet événement moi
je trouve que déjà ils les ont réussi à
garder un esprit assez familial et
convivial il y a des grands champions
qui vont faire cette course mais je
trouve qu'elle est assez fédératrice et
puis Alain le disait le côté
nature qui est bien représentée dans les
différents parcours et dans les
différents tracés de cette course sans
oublier le patrimoine aussi bâti puisque
je sais plus combien de villages seront
traversés par par la course et notamment
il y a l'Association des Maires Ruraux
d'ailleurs des Yvelines qui est
partenaires et c'est pas pour rien parce
que ce sera aussi à une formidable
occasion de mettre en lumière le
patrimoine yvinois vous en pensez quoi
vous Laurent palot ce sont les mêmes
raisons qui pour vous font ce cette
renommée ce succès on est seulement à
quatre éditions on le rappelle c'est une
vraie course nature comme le disait
Alain et Jean-Baptiste et je crois que
c'est le seul ultra trail qu'on a dans
le 78 donc forcément ça va attirer du
monde une nouvelle course et ça fait du
bien autre chose que le l'urbain et
c'est tout naturel pour vous en tant que
partenaire d'être aux côtés d'un tel
événement ah bah on ne peut que être
partenaire d'un tel événement dans le 78
en Jean-Baptiste sabonique vous faites
partie donc des participants vous allez
faire le 100 km du coup vous êtes bien
renseigné
après mûre réflexion je vais essayer de
faire mon premier ultra trail et donc je
me suis dit que pour le premier ultra
trail on allait le faire dans son
département dans mon département donc
dans les Yvelines j'en avais suivi aux
aventures alors à distance avec Cédric
Pembe marine le maire du Port-Marly sur
le Half Marathon des Sables engagé
justement pour l'association Messenger
cardiaque je vois que Laurent palot
porte le t-shirt vous êtes venu aussi
avec la petite mascotte de Messenger
cardiaque votre aventure avait permis
sur le Half marathon des sables de
sauver deux enfants malades du cœur vous
êtes inscrit sur on va dire sur les
mêmes objectifs c'est toujours au profit
de mes Sénat chirurgie cardiaques oui
tout à fait bah alors avec l'association
les élus du cœur qu'on a confondé avec
Cédric pembemamine mère du Port-Marly on
a clôturé toute la mobilisation de
l'année 2022 via une soirée de
remerciement la semaine passée et donc
ce sont non pas deux mais trois enfants
qui vont être sauvés qui vont pouvoir
bénéficier d'une opération cardiaque et
donc là on se lance sur 2023 avec de
nouveaux de nouveaux défis sportifs on
on en parlera mais on repartira dans des
airs en fin d'année mais on a voulu
aussi faire différentes courses
d'ailleurs pas uniquement de la course
il y aura aussi du Golfe du vélo à
proximité dans le département dans la
région et donc on a eu la chance il y en
a la chance d'être partenaire
aujourd'hui de la diagonale des Yvelines
on sera 25 élus du cœur à prendre le
départ la grande majorité sur le vin km
en courra au profit de mes snacks
chirurgical avec le maillot que Laurent
harborphyrvan et puis et puis je
remercie aussi l'organisation puisque un
euro par dossard sera également reversé
à l'association de messages chirurgie
cardiaque ça c'est important de donner
une dimension caritative solidaire à
votre événement alors c'était c'était
pas la c'était pas l'objectif de départ
mais c'est vrai que quand Jean-Baptiste
m'a concerté à ce sujet ça devenait une
évidence et et quand j'ai assisté la
dernière fois à la petite soirée de
remise du chèque que vous aviez récolté
l'année dernière c'est vrai que c'est
une grande émotion franchement qu'on
puisse participer dans nos moyens aider
à sauver un enfant franchement voilà
c'était pas le but au départ mais si on
peut le contribuer on est on est très
content et à aventure
s'associe à ça et on est on est vraiment
très heureux et je pense que une
contribution de chacun ça fait du bien
et puis ça va apporter peut-être le
bonheur dans une famille donc c'est
génial voilà aussi Laurent Pagot
j'imagine ça aussi un tube je vois que
vous portez ce t-shirt aussi vous
l'arborez on l'arborde parce que parce
que c'est important parce que les élus
du cœur moi j'ai rencontré Jean-Baptiste
il y a peu de temps mais au travers des
élus du cœur et pour pour son engagement
sur la course tout ça donc oui oui on
s'engage là dessus et puis et puis quand
on voit qu'une course comme ça va
pousser aussi cette belle association on
peut que être partenaire de ses courses
on va parler les quatre parcours vous
disiez alors l'idée c'est aussi d'ouvrir
à tout le monde finalement cette Ecotral
que ça s'adresse au plus grand nombre
c'est aussi pour ça qu'il y a quatre
parcours différents qui sont proposés
oui tout à fait alors nous
on organise depuis avec AES N78
plusieurs courses depuis pratiquement 20
ans ça fait un moment qu'on travaille
là-dessus donc les Yvelines on reconnaît
bien tous les on le connaît même très
bien et c'est vrai que
quand on s'est dit bon on va faire un
100 km parce que c'est un tenait à cœur
depuis quelques années mais c'est quand
même assez c'est une niche quand même
courir sans qu'il soit tout le monde
Jean-Baptiste
on va parler de sa préparation dans un
instant on parlera samedi
mais donc voilà il fallait quand même
que on reste un ça reste un challenge
aussi pour d'autres coureurs du 20 km
l'année dernière il y avait pas de 12
cette année on a décidé de mettre un
autre parce que il y avait eu des
demandes ce sujet le bois de Rochefort
s'y prêtait aussi bien pour le 12 et
pour le 20 donc c'est ça devenait une
div de proposer quatre distances il y en
a que la dernière pour faire un vin qui
sont mis sur le 50 peut-être sur du 50
ils se mettra sur le sang l'année
prochaine moyenne petite évolution on
s'arrêtera là je pense je sais que
beaucoup de coureurs me disent pourquoi
pas un aller-retour
c'est du boulot quand même ouais ça se
passe pas comment un
Ultra Trail de 100 km on vous a croisé
souvent sur des événements running dans
les Yvelines mais là c'est quand même on
va dire une plus grande distance comment
ça se passe notamment d'ailleurs sur
ceux qui sont organisés par Alain moi je
suis tombé amoureux de la course des
flambeaux à Montfort-l'Amaury je la
trouve magnifique c'est une course
nocturne 78 kg vraiment tout à fait on
se on se prépare comme on peut dans le
peu de temps qui nous reste dans notre
quotidien professionnel donc dans ma
fonction de maire en l'occurrence je
pourrais être beaucoup plus assidu à
l'entraînement ça c'est certain non mais
en ayant une bonne nutrition une bonne
hydratation
on essaie de récupérer aussi un peu de
un peu de sommeil ce qui est pas
toujours chose facile voilà moi
l'objectif c'est de finir ce premier je
me donne pas d'autres d'autres objectifs
ce sera déjà très bien parce que ce sera
le premier et puis surtout remercier
l'ensemble des collègues et des amis aux
élus du cœur qui vont s'engager sur
aussi les autres distances il y en a
pour tous les niveaux c'est ce que je
trouve très bien sur cette diagonale des
Yvelines et donc que toutes ces
personnes là puisse se retrouver sur
rassembler et aller mouiller le maillot
pour et bien la bonne cause moi ça me
sent mauvais jeu de mots en tout cas ça
me fait chaud au cœur une course fort
c'est le 100 km les les difficultés sur
ce parcours qui veut en parler Laurent
est-ce que vous souhaitez en parler
est-ce qu'il y a des des difficultés
particulières à noter sur ce parcours
c'est un peu long pour ceux qui font 100
km certes il y a un peu d'eau j'ai cru
voir un certain endroit qui vont être
qui vont être sympathiques et puis la
finale je crois que Allah on a parlé au
château de Rochefort-en-Yvelines un
final en montée je dis pas de bêtises
alors les 12 derniers kilomètres il y a
il y a le le bois de Rochefort est et
bien pourvu en dénivelé
non on arrivera dans la salle
polyvalente de Rochefort
monsieur Sylvain Lambert maire de
Rochefort nous accueille depuis 4 ans et
depuis 5 ans même maintenant parce que
voilà et donc
ouais le dénivelé le la fin de parcours
je pense qu'on va laisser des traces
Jean-Baptiste il faut que tu gardes un
petit peu fort et puis la difficulté
c'est que alors on nous reproche
beaucoup que on n'a pas trop de dénivelé
sur notre territoire ben voilà c'est
notre territoire on passera quand même
parler votre Cernay donc les votre
Cernay ça va laisser aussi un petit peu
de traces et puis la difficulté c'est de
courir ça peut paraître bête mais en fin
de compte c'est de tenir un rythme de à
peu près un peu en dessous de 7 km/h
pour pour les plus longs ça reste quand
même une performance sur 100 km ça reste
quand même une performance on rappelle
un départ de Breuil Bois Robert arriver
à
Rochefort-en-Yvelines dans un
département des Yvelines on l'a compris
qu'il se prête tout à fait à ce genre
d'événements qu'est-ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter une bonne météo est-ce que les
prévisions sont bonnes là pour samedi
j'ai pas pu les regarder encore ça qu'un
jour que je passe je suis sur mon écran
de le matériel obligatoire il a demandé
des palmes
il y avait il y a quelques passages
quelques passages qui vont être boueux
ça c'est évident il y a des passages où
on va voir un petit peu d'eau chevilles
ça c'est évident aussi la météo bah là
j'ai vu ce matin à c'est plutôt plutôt
correct avec quelques pluies mais bon ça
devrait voilà ça je vais juste gêné pour
l'arrivée ou pour manger la tartiflette
puisque il y aura une tartiflette à
l'arrivée voilà bon il y aura le après
l'effort le réconfort comment on dit en
tout cas merci à vous trois d'être venu
en parler en plateau et je rappelle donc
que la diag 78 sera ce samedi entre
Breuil Bois Robert et Rochefort en ligne
ça c'est pour le 100 km mais bien sûr on
l'a dit à 4 parcours qui sont proposés
vous retrouvez toutes les informations
sur le site Internet de l'événement